let's go live now - damn you Daniel
Schwimmer Daniel let's take us through
first of all the statements by Brazil's
president it doesn't sound like he's
been much swayed by the International
reaction to this now I think part of his
politics Sammy is that he likes to defy
the opinion in the international opinion
he's also a man who came to power during
his electoral campaign last year saying
that this region was ripe for
development
he saw the indigenous communities and
the environmental lobby as an impediment
to development and he's there now been
in a meeting with his governor with
governors of the Amazon region with some
of his cabinet ministers and very much
that same message has come out of that
meeting with some governor's saying they
simply don't have the resources to spend
on the government agencies which are
meant to protect this region and others
from the job also NarL himself saying
he's frustrated brazil is frustrated
that they're so much of this land in
this region is protected either as
nature reserves or as a demarcated
indigenous land that they they want to
see Brazil develop they want to see
Brazil richer and it's a very different
message to that coming out of the
international community we say that it
feels it has a right to to protect the
Amazon rainforest which is in Brazil so
it sounds like they're walking a fine
line then between saying there on top of
these fires and whether they think these
fires are really an environmental
disaster or perhaps in an economic gain
for the country well I think I think
it's very much that I mean they don't
see it as an environmental disaster you
can see I'm standing in a burnt field
now just outside Bordeaux Vale they is
something they do every year that's
environment local environment secretary
you saw in the package he says it's a
problem that they can contain it's a
natural phenomenon here there's a
culture here of burning as we mentioned
the rainy season is just coming we're
not going to see much in the way of
fires to the next few months
but almost certainly we will see massive
fires next year I mean they broke all
right
this year there were twice as many as
there were in 2018 next year it's quite
likely given the economic given the
environmental conditions that we will
see even more fires because of the
conditions being created by this
government more people are likely to
come to this region and start more fires
that seems almost certain what the
international community can do about
that other than criticize if the money
they're offering is being is being
spurned what they can do about that is
unclear the pressure is mounting but job
Orson are on his government seemed
intent on defying that criticism all
right thanks so much Daniel shrine levae
and fires have been burning throughout
the Amazon rainforest at record levels
this year seventy seven thousand flames
have been recorded across brazil over
the last 12 months this map from NASA
shows those burning across South America
right now satellite imaging also shows
the amount of carbon monoxide these
fires have produced this month alone in
less than two weeks they've pushed the
levels by nearly two-thirds carbon
monoxide plays a huge role in air
pollution and climate change the Amazon
is often referred to as the lungs of the
earth because of the amount of carbon
dioxide it absorbs an oxygen it produces
basically supplying more than 20% of the
world's oxygen Erika bérenger is senior
biodiversity research associate at the
University of Oxford she joins us by
Skype from Oxford in the United Kingdom
good to have you with us so let me get
you if I may to respond to the sort of
message that's coming out of officials
in Brazil that hey this is kind of like
a seasonal cyclical event the fires
burning but to be clear the scale of the
burning this year is much bigger than
usual right yes correct and one thing
that I think it's really important to
get clear is that these fires are not
natural they don't start because of
climatic conditions fires and amazon
need a human ignition source so someone
needs to put fire somewhere for the fire
to spread
in the water you're seeing fires that
are related to the forest station
so first the forest is chopped down then
it's satellite after few months dry and
during the dry season you satellite for
it to become ashes and then it's
possible to put pressure on so what we
are seeing this year the scale of the
fires here is related to the first
station the first station numbers have
been increasing fairly according to the
numbers from the Brazilian space and
agency and that is bound to and Viacom
pained by a high number of fires all
right so we've got a lot of carbon
monoxide being released into the
atmosphere what will that mean for
climate change in the environment this
is a huge problem because the Amazon
alone stores the equivalent of a hundred
years of co2 emissions and from the US
that's how much carbon is locked into
the Amazon in a moment that cut it down
and put on fire all the carbon goes to
that Padma sphere either a co2 or carbon
monoxide as you mentioned so of course
it's gonna have a huge impact in to
accelerating climate change mmm what
about all that smoke and rainfall what
will it do to rainfall so we have seen
the rainfall patterns change in regions
with high levels of the first station in
Amazon and then the dry season becomes
longer because the last rain is being
generated by the forest but one aspect
here about the smoke is about people's
house so we see that in years of
extremely high fire occurrence like 2019
there is in average an increase of 200%
hospital admissions of children with
respiratory diseases so this is not only
an environmental environmental issue but
also a social one and I wonder if you
could just clear one thing out you know
we often refer to the Amazon as the
lungs of there are those who say no the
oxygen comes that's it's kind of being
misrepresented the oxygen comes from the
Seas and so on could you clarify from a
scientific assay what exactly the role
that the Amazon forest plays for the
availability of oxygen
producer of oxygen but it consumes a lot
of part of the oxygen it produces
because of course large organisms large
trees need to absorb a lot of carbon
sorry a lot of oxygen to stay alive and
but algae in the oceans are the largest
source of oxygen so they are the true
length of the world so the M is gonna be
more like the air corner of the world
something that keeps the climate and it
helps to fight a climate change keep the
carbon lock down but one aspect here is
that it's not because the amazons not
the lungs of the world that we shouldn't
protect it because it's really important
for climate just for different reasons
right right that it's more about
preserving the carbon monoxide and not
releasing it into the world rather than
producing right got it thank you so much
it's been a really interesting
conversation thank you